I welcomed into this video oops playing
Grand Master God wound Goldman this is
alex under its Alexander right boost him
off let's check yeah I guess understand
off I'm very good GM he's got the
Belarus flag some think originally from
Russia not sure wise God's flag ok we
have a an opening that is usually
associated with the Ukrainian
Grandmaster or like Roman ishing this
set up with them with a six and b5 it's
a quite interesting way to play for
black against those g3 setups it's a bit
more more active than some other lines
not 100 / stour wider place this ok if
he goes d5 probably going to take and
play deform going for hanging pawns but
yeah very often it's simply a d6 that
it's that displayed like a queen to e2
he maybe we'll play on before sending my
night to the room let's let's play some
small improving moves what about UFOs
this may be an idea I guess so if is not
bad at all
he cannot easily play d5 I can capture
and maybe rookie one night edge from
play on the farm k how to proceed the
way to improve here would be a form I
was thinking about night eh draw this
was my day or night age to then F form
and you might be able to play d 5 at the
right moment okay anyway this is get
against d5 ed ed night f5 I know
probably it's not fatal the 911 can play
Bishop evade but I like to prepare and
form yes yeah this was the move that
made me hesitate with night h4 but i
think that the capture is not a not a
big problem it damages my pawn structure
but it opens the G file and yeah it's
probably right its decision ok let's
drop back and now I have managed to play
a form yeah G for each for g 5s the idea
he might play g5 now that's it's
possible
maybe g fire no it's not going for that
okay should I play Knight a form with
tempo or 92 yeah 92 is probably better I
am I will need the night on the King
side maybe you can take a plea d5 now
gaining counter play in the center hmm
yeah he's doing that but night g3 we 593
probably taking I don't like okay let's
do that you can take on e4 and play
discovery with the night I thought that
rocked it to would be an answer that we
need to this maybe 96 and 93 ok ok ok ok
let's let's play that so Knight takes
our queen tags if I take what the night
93 as possible is it is a dangerous the
other question mmm tasty is going to
play look the eighth with tempo and then
23 Bishop Jake's I'm not sure and then
down long time I should have played
quick I'm as you know
93 our plane 91 this should just be an
exchange I mean an exchange of pieces I
maybe maybe you can I g6 channel that I
think of it yeah but Ruby one you cannot
take on f4 check check yes I've got many
pawns on light squares this is true i
take night takes this is ugly yeah I
know it's another point on light squares
but I don't think I have any choice the
position is very very close however so
well maybe it's still it's still
playable I came he's trying King f6 and
stuff how to how to play
yeah this is the kind of game well if
you play black and you don't win your
very annoyed because it looks like why
just played nonsense all the time and
still on it's not lost I'm not sure if
I'm losing here and so it's close it's
very close and no the other one of
course immediately spotted this of
course ah stupid very I should have at
least played a time morning late a bit a
bit tougher yeah okay I can I can resign
that white person's just h three SS is
gone I need to pay to play that it's
probably lost anyway because of age five
and he's getting the pawn yeah this is
lost anyway I like the other night
exchange was actually helping actually
helping him a very bad play I just need
to take this is the point I need I just
need to take this is much better much
better defense maybe it's losing anyway
but this is the way I should should play
now he cannot he cannot take on f5 and
get the protected paso it's um yeah it's
still it's still ugly for white but it's
not clear that I'm losing you can try
all kinds of things Bishop around here
f6 h5 and I've got all pawns on light
squares which is ugly maybe it's still
terrible but very ugly chess of course
the AG five is of course the to keep the
key move
if I'm able to prevent that then
everything's fine and then now I need to
play a five I cannot really play
something else cannot let's say here it
just takes it I have no choice and I'm
if I take their to to pawn saying so
probably I need I need to do something
else yeah to be honest after the one I
completely forgot that he can take it if
I thought you would you need to play
something like that and then I have any
five this was my my idea and I probably
forgot that you can take check probably
instead of rook the one I should play
this move opening the diagonal and
making sure that my bishop is not so bad
checks there may be something like that
note that this night is really a bad
piece and I have maybe 94 maybe this
month is better I really forgot that you
can take on you wanna and edgy flying
for some obvious i called the move
before he played it last ugly move
anyway I had g5 early anoche i was
playing this instantly and now i need to
really hunker down in this this ugly
position yeah but the key point is I
need to take on e6 I really forgot that
this is this is just too bad here must
take this the last possible um chance to
take to maybe try to secure draw but
it's probably I have a bad feeling about
this alright thanks for watching